what is Beachbody on demand it is an
easy-to-use streaming service that gives
you instant access to a wide variety of
super effective workouts you can do from
the comfort of your living room are you
in your living room or are you just kind
of killing time change that now
Beachbody on demand it has a history of
success this is the same company behind
p90x where you see that asian guy
getting jacked up on your set insanity
21 day fix t25 Brazil Butt Lift all of
those things three week yoga retreat and
more you can jump on there and bang bang
bang next thing you know you're doing
crunches you're looking at your husband
you're playing cards with your cousin
and also getting in shape in your living
room work out on your scheduled workouts
as short as 10 minute abs I mean 10
minutes that doesn't require any extra
equipment you don't have a um you don't
have barbells you don't have a gun rack
you don't have special stuff doesn't
matter access anywhere anytime on your
computer tablet smartphone Roku and
Apple TV it's the best deal in fitness
and listeners of this past weekend can
try it absolutely free that's right I
want you to try this service because
I've been on there and I've done that
three week yoga retreat and I get in
there and bam Kapow next thing you know
my abs my neck and my crack all
stretched out I'm feeling fine ready for
everyday right now my listeners can get
a special free trial membership when you
text tpw two three zero three zero three
zero that's right just text tpw to 30 30
30 and you will get up full access to
this entire platform for free that's
right try it out don't have any money
still get in shape free stuff at beach
body on demand fitness now
all right
this Monday April 16
it's Monday April 16th
this is some day man it's another day
that these uh that the Sun and the moon
and whoever else made facade and
transformers Voltron everybody everybody
making it happen everybody making it
happen oh good to be here with you guys
i I just let's get into it I just got
back from from my hometown you know I
was down there in Covington Louisiana
down there
and man we were shooting a pilot for
this for this project it's like a
low-key small-town detective series so
you know big-time shows they have like
Dateline murder mystery you got to
really murder somebody you got a you
know you got to chop off somebody's arm
or steal somebody's wig or but with
their head hook to it to really make
that you know to make a real crime but
in this show that we were pitching it's
more about small town mystery crime
paranormal you know the kind of
that you know you don't know what
happened you know I'm saying you played
hide-and-go-seek and uh the one dude
y'all never found but if you go out in
the woods at night you can still hear
him counting you know that kind of stuff
somebody stole a pie off of somebody
windowsill and then suddenly everybody
had diabetes in the whole town you know
a bunch of lice came through and and
things got crazy a buncha lice came
through and they made it with termites
and next thing you know they had people
um you know they had little bugs that
were eating houses and making people
each so it's that kind of show where you
go into small towns and you investigate
what could be happening so that's what I
did man I just got back today and we had
a good time we had a good time down
there in Covington Louisiana and what do
you guys been up to man what do you guys
been up to what you've been up to in
your life what's going on somebody had a
birthday this weekend
sometimes things happen so fast I don't
it's like and I don't know if it's
because I'm older or because you get
used to doing things but things happen
so fast it's like I can't even it's not
that I can't enjoy him it's just that I
don't know I guess I've just gotten used
to him you know he used to be remember
when you first went over to somebody's
house for a birthday party
well you remember that remember it was
like oh um you know Kenneth is having a
party and you got an invitation remember
that you got an invitation and
that's just said Kenneth house or if his
parents were divorced you'd be like
Kenneth's dad's house 1:00 p.m. to 2:00
p.m. I said only lasts at an hour when
you were a kid boy that lasted one
hour and do you got up early you got up
early as hell and a lot of times if we
had to get somebody a gift but what my
mom would do is say look around the
house
find something Kenneth would like and
that was like a test as to how greedy
you were or not because you know good
and well I'm not giving Kenneth the nice
you know good and well I ain't
giving little little a little itchy ass
Kenneth the good I'm not giving him
a new toy that I hadn't opened or you
know some money or anything so I go
around the house bro come back to my
mama about maybe an hour later have
something more just sitting a little box
or bag I'm looking there if just be like
my bed sheet just fold it up I'd be like
this is for Kenneth I'm like what the
you're giving Kenny their bed sheet
that's insane go find something else for
Kenneth and you would do something while
you and maybe break Kenneth off a couple
cheese slices or something you know or
maybe something uh you know you wrap him
up a couple of batteries or something it
was just different you find anything
around the house Oh Kenneth will
this Philips head screwdriver
next thing you know four year old
Kenneth out there what a phillips-head
it's just those were the days but
remember that when you went to
somebody's party you're like mom is it
time to go yet she's like no it's 9:00
a.m. you my call
what comes after 9:00 1:00 p.m. and
she'll be like nah no wonder you wrapped
up a bad sheet for Kenneth but that was
it you were so excited you a brush do
you a brush your hair you will comb your
hair and brush your hair
I remember combing and brushing my
putting that hairspray dude because I
grew up in the hairspray belt you know
I'm you fix all everybody put hairspray
hairspray on everything you know
sometimes if your carpet got real old
and mashed down I remember in my
neighborhood a lot of mothers would go
around with like a will a brillo brush
kind of and brush it up and then spray
it with hairspray to give it that pop
you know to give it a give your step
that giving you know put a little bit of
it will it will put a little bit of
crunch under your bare foot in the house
but it would give you a carpet that lift
make it look fresh and new right off
that carpet truck because they also had
if you wanted to get carpet they had a
carpet truck about every six months come
through and it would park up there off
Ali Road down by where I was from and
you go up there and pick a color out and
they'd have three or four colors you
know maybe get you one of the colors
would always be crazy you'd be
like damn they got a they got a fuchsia
so but you know a couple sisters come
through and grab that fuchsia at the
gate a couple brothers are a couple
local white dudes come through and they
put carpet in their car I mean
it wasn't crazy when I was young to get
into somebody's car and have a fully
covered in carpet I mean it was just a
different time back then it was just
more of a style thing but yeah you
remember that birthday party and then
there was Kenneth's gift and
that thing was sitting on the table man
all morning you had to walk around and
just
you were like man why Kenneth
gettin everything and I ain't getting
nothin and by about 11 a.m. your mother
that's what your mom would be here and I
never get anything
Kenneth gets everything and meanwhile
you don't even know who Kenneth
is you were one of those second or third
degree friends that you just got you
know that was back when you got invited
because you had to you know that was
like the old Facebook four year old
birthday parties it was like you had to
know people you had no escape
so 11:00 a.m. you crying now in the
living room
Kenneth's is all wrapped up you
can't even remember what you got him you
didn't get him you gave him
a couple color pencils that you had you
know and maybe a yo-yo y'all got a
little 40 cent yo-yo or something put it
in there meanwhile you don't even know
Kenneth the dude in your class ain't
even got any arms so now you
getting an armless Chitty yo-yo but
you're not even there yet so you crying
you pissed off your mom's pissed off now
she's yelling Kenneth
Kenneth's party and now you're defending
yourself ending Kenneth Kenneth his mom
is a nice lady now your mom's pissed at
Kenneth's mom your mom starts whoopin
your ass cuz you're crying and screaming
and fighting in the living room now you
got you ass beat and you cry yourself to
sleep you take about a 40-minute nap
it's 20 to 1 you get up it's time to go
to Kenneth's and you get to Kenneth's
and man the place is lit the place is
lit as people got kool-aid all
color on their mouth from drinking
kool-aid they got that one 4 year old
kid he can't even talk yet you
know they got another they got one kid
sitting by themselves just looking at
the wall they got that kid little Andrea
you know and they just live in life and
if somebody's in the backyard and
somebody ran and you know they got a
sprinkler going and it's a real
but it don't matter because
this is Kenneth
party those are the days man I remember
those days
and we would go to this place called
roller Kingdom now sometime whenever you
got about 6 or 7 you know you was able
to skate you had you had that ability to
skate and so you go to straight-up
roller Kingdom man it was dark in there
and people touching each other's
and everything all kind of wild
you and I mean it's so dark you
you'll you know you'll lick your
you lick your sister's Chilean in there
and that's natural activity out there
when you cuz look man with roller skates
come on that got me hard bruh I was
that little jouster out there on them
skates dude obviously be jousting with
an erect you know I'll be out there just
skating but with that erection and when
you're young you get that erection but I
don't kind of hide it now if I get an
erection I'm like uh somebody's going to
complain or start something but when I
was young over there by roller Kingdom
and I'm popping off you know you know
and I'm sprouting I'll push my pelvis
forward boy I skate penis first boy I
want everybody to see that I'm here to
battle the dragon and that's how I do it
and those were fun man I remember the
little kids parties do one kids house I
went over to I was just hit about hip
her buddy I went over to this one boy's
house and neck I didn't even go to the
party you the party's in the
backyard
I saw his sister's bedroom did I stopped
in there have my head in her panty
drawer bruh did I had my face in that
panty drawer for probably that
whole hour that whole hour birthday cuz
you know come about 1:55 p.m. boy I
heard my mom calling from the living
room or honking my mom was that
mom that will pull up and honk start
honk and didn't get she didn't give a
about meeting your mom she didn't
give a she didn't give a damn about
meeting your dad she was like the only
single mom so then other all these dads
were always trying to meet her and
and walk me out to the car my mom didn't
give a my mom won't even stop the
car sometimes she's
lowdown as slow as a car could go you
know maybe which is maybe about you know
40 feet every maybe seven seconds she
was slow down as slow as you could go
and then you'd have to get in man my mom
wasn't playing mom didn't play
my mom was efficient and pissed off and
that's where I came from but yeah this
weekend we're back in my hometown man
and it was great it was kind of crazy
going back like we had a crew of about
eight of us went down there and this
show is like you know to like a Scully
and Mulder and we we chase small-town
crimes you know you know and it could be
anything you know a house went missing
or you know they find it a bunch of um
you know baby doll heads in the woods
that kind of stuff you know the dark
hearts we out there chasing it and in my
town a bunch of monkeys got out you know
when I was young and a couple of times a
bunch of monkeys got out of the primate
Center and they were living and hiding
in different places and hiding in the
dumpster by the Popeyes Chicken
they caught a couple eating pizza and
they're up to some wild in my town
you know they were doing all kinds of
lab testing out there making different
hybrid animals you know what I'm talking
about they have like a like you know an
aliquot which is just like an alligator
and a Swan rat crows you know you get
that raccoon in that crow they got
everything and so you know up and in my
time they've had rumors of all types of
wild activity Humanzee is chimp Youmans
so we got in there and started just
asking around then we interviewed people
that have been fired from the place from
this primate center we interviewed the
man that was a director there for 30
years we got into it boy we were
traveling around we had an old Grand
Marquis and my sidekick this beautiful
young comedian and we got into it man so
and what else didn't make me think of Oh
went to mold Junior High School and that
was pretty cool man that's where I got a
lot of my early erections were in junior
high so even just getting back in that
building it made me feel
I guess it made me feel a little bit old
but it reminded me of something just
damn standout erections because I had
this early thing this habit when I would
get an erection when I was young you
know when I was really young I didn't
know what was happening I would get one
and I would put it on set it on a piece
of paper and I get my pencil and draw an
outline around it and save it you know
cuz that way if I went to the doctor I
could show the doctor kind of what was
happening you know just show him these
you know just us you know these Cox
sketches and so I would just outline
that sucker and just outline it and do
all of that and my penis had that low
key curve to it two out of the gate I
think you know I don't know if my penis
was really ready to be erect because
sometimes you you know some things
you're ready for in life and some things
you're not and I don't know if my penis
was really ready to be erect when it was
but I think my imagination started
reaching out you know reaching for ideas
of of breasts and vulgarity and crotches
and all of that and so my mind was
reaching out for these dark arts and
then my penis your penis will follow
your imagination your penis is just it's
basically the little brother to your
imagination I mean it just tags along
behind you know it's like the shadow of
your imagination and if your imagination
is sprung then that penis starts to dis
but my penis had that Loki curve to it
you know that little just like it was
trying to just kind of peek around a
cabbage ball you know like it was trying
to peek around a small cantaloupe like
it heard something in the next room you
know I had that wild boner but uh-oh
they listen to this speaking of boners
okay I'm on the flight home and I fell
asleep you know I fell asleep on the
plane of natural causes and I wake up
there's a lady next to me handing me a
blanket and she said sure oh and she
said sir
your body is showing like what
is going on and she goes your body sir
and I'm looking down and I'm sprung up
you know I'm showing root you know I'm
full I'm erect because I wear these
special pants sometimes when I fly and
they um you know keep a lot of blood
from going into my legs and everything
is sometime that blood will store up in
my wiener and I'm erect and this lady's
like I don't want to have to call the
flight attendant like what and I'm
thinking at first I thought well you
know I didn't really in my mind I'm like
I just woke up like what am i doing you
know am i doing something odd or profane
no and uh and she this lady's basically
is is calling me out because I have an
erection because I'm a natural man on an
airplane and this frickin frump I mean
this lady was a straight-up frump c'n
you know look like a little she looked
kind of like a dude but like kind of
like just let kind of maybe decent legs
kind of she look like a full trash bag
but somebody had put like legs on it
then it maybe ran a 5k but about six
years ago you know she looked like she
had just kind of big tits but not even
cool tis you know really just more belly
hiding in her breasts really and it was
she was like just kind of jacked in the
chest
you know this straight up from can she
was from New York or Jersey or something
just kind of a know-it-all kana and her
husband sitting right there and like it
was something you know like I'm like I'm
sorry ma'am you know that's a natural
thing you know I'm aside I mean I'm
sleeping and she goes she's like yeah
well you know it's not very appropriate
is it is the word that she used with me
and that's what shook me what's not
appropriate I can't have an erection
first of all it ain't for you this
ain't your erection it did the funny
thing is I'd have to fall asleep next to
you to even get an erection because you
look like somebody that just do chest
exercises every day since they were
about 16 months old and you got a big
old jack chest and nothing else
your breasts look all freaking your
breasts look like two - just fat
kids asleep in the Sun and one of them
got some moles on it and look like
somebody spilled chocolate on one of
them chubby boys and you trying to tell
me and her hugs and I'm looking at her
husband like dude you're not gonna you
know I got an erection in my sleep
you're not gonna back me up
white dude both of more white
and it's just like damn did I looked at
that dude I was like wow you're a you're
a man
your wife sitting here and how can I get
called out for having an erection like
that's a crime none of us would be
here if it wasn't for an erection you
stupid Muppet you from can latte man if
that was a drink I would spill
that man
just made me mad and I'm sorry I'm not
trying to get angry but I can't get an
erection in my sleep anymore in public
and I don't know if an airplane's public
it's it's got to be international waters
but err we're in the freakin sky I'm
halfway to the Sun lady don't be shocked
if I erect up okay don't be shocked if
my starts looking for you know
looking for some hope
my body's probably scared I'm you know
30,000 feet off the earth and things
happen in a man I mean he could tell
this B they didn't have any sex like
this couple you know not that I have
really of a good one but just made me
man you know what it made me feel like I
mean I guess it made me like feel bad
for being like a man or something or she
was making me feel like you know because
I had an erection or something that I
was being y-you know that I was you know
like hey I mean is that what it's come
to you can't even be a man anymore I had
pants on and Underpants you know those
are that's the correct amount of
coverings you know and just because you
know I mean uh I don't know just make me
man you know it obviously made man I'm
still upset about
just made me mad you can't I can't
you know I'm showing a little what if
somebody's pregnant they can't show
their work you know this just like high
school I'm showing my work lady that's
it it's just like grade school you know
what if somebody's pregnant I'm like
excuse me ma'am
you're gonna need to tone that down no I
wouldn't say that you know it's just
frickin lady it's just some of this
attitude out there that like I can't a
man can't even be a human you
know like there's this crime against men
or something I don't know what this
lady's problem was and plus I got a
decent wiener you know I got that short
fat but that thang big boy it's like
that fat dude at school you know
and after the 9th or 10th grade he quit
coming to school because he was just too
he got too big you know they didn't make
enough shirts locally that could really
partner with him to get him comfortably
in a school when he was just stay at the
house topless and do homeschool but
still learn and people go visit him on
the weekends and stuff until people
started to forget about him but that's
what I got that short fat you know I got
that young mayoral candidate and just
because I'm bringing heat and this
ladies over here frosty as hell I should
have said man I wish I would have said
something I wish I would have said
something makes me you know just makes
me just makes me mad anyway I don't mean
I harp on that but damn it's a crime to
get it never and you know what's funny
is I felt like there's a couple months
ago I was somewhere and I got an
erection this is during you know when
the meet - times up stuff was you know
when every celebrity suddenly and you
know as a victim of rape and everything
you know said it's amazing how many
celebrities will jump on that ship
immediately you know I was right I was
it's like we've all been everybody's
been sexually abused it seems like in
some way I mean here's one thing we've
all been abused why don't we just agree
there so we can get it's like it's like
everybody trying to out be abused it's
like oh I've been abused I've been a bit
of an abused you know you know I was
well I was mentally how was Malaya
I was molested by a you know one of my
favorite lambs we had some lambs and I
was molested by him at church during
school you know by my step you know
mothers grandmothers father you know in
the past and the future on drugs yes it
happened to me too
I'm not shown in the movement but it's
just like you know it's like
everything's just it's just everything
just a part of it you know like this guy
Comey or whatever is coming out about
the electrum pand they're in a big fight
I don't trust any of these Muppets I
never trusted any of them since I was a
kid politicians do you know we are
member growing up when you're poor
politicians don't give a about you
they don't give a it no matter what
color you are I mean they say that they
do they don't give you the same problems
I've been in around in America since I
was a kid you know these politicians
aren't doing anything it's just a little
show that's what I think but these Comey
and all these people that all fight and
did I think it's hilarious
I think it's all the WWE now but then
everybody everybody's selling that book
oh here's the book about it well you
know there's no truth to theta a if
there's a book attached to it how much
is truth and how much is PR boy but they
um what I'm talking about oh I remember
this do one thing I noticed man I miss
gravel driveways it's just someone
hadn't seen in so long and we got out
into the sticks dude we went and
interviewed um a friend of Mines brother
while we were in my town and we just
this dude man he he had the slowest
drawl when he would say come on he'd be
like yeah man it had me laughing so hard
yeah yeah
but they had gravel driveways remember
gravel driveways that was lit
somebody was upset or you went outside
and you were upset you could grab a
piece of your driveway and throw
it at somebody how awesome was that you
can't do with this concrete you gotta
have a hammer you gotta have all of this
you got to have a slingshot you
know or like a buddy to be one of those
big huge slingshots you get have three
people to even you know fire off a piece
of that big granite or whatever driveway
granite but when I was a kid well you
walk outside somebody pissed you off you
pick up a piece of your driveway
and throw it at that oh it was cool I
missed that oh you hope oh really really
really pick that thing a walk do most of
us half the time we were outside all we
did was standing around throwing rocks
at a stop sign if you've ever done that
boy then we have a lot in common
and I don't care what color you are
white black Latino you know different
color one thing it was pretty cool is at
my middle school this or my junior high
school this past weekend and you know a
girl that I used to have a you know a
little bit of a crush on and used to
take you know ice to ride to school with
her sometimes and her mother would give
me a ride to school they she's gonna be
the principal soon and one of the last
teachers that still works there from
when I went to school there is retiring
this year
mr. Heidelberg and he used to you know
he used to run the the low-key uh the
you know special kid you know he'd be
running all these special kids and
that's where that dude Brian st. Pierre
that's where this young dude he was the
first wig ever the first white kid that
wanted to be black ever and they put him
in learning disabled classes because
they'd never seen it before
so you know you had kids with real
learning disabilities then you have
frickin you know Brian st. P just
wearing this this Charlotte Hornets
starter pullover you know just shooting
invisible jumpers all day on the back
some mentally handicapped kids you know
just doing fake dunks on people that was
drool
and running life like that but
Heidelberg is retiring that dudes
retiring but we went on to UM what did I
want to say oh we went yeah we went on
to the old school we just got to walk
around my old school and it was just you
know you know it was unique to be an
adult now when I was at the school they
said that one thing that they don't have
much of anymore is they don't have as
much racial tension as they used to when
I was a kid and that was pretty cool to
hear you know because you know at the
school that was probably maybe I felt
like it was like 60/40 white/black for
kids and that's all they had you know I
didn't have a lot of we didn't have a
lot of other diversity now there's a
little bit more but but it was really
cool to hear you know this young lady
and this uh this other gentleman who
were you know teaching at the school and
who are you know potential principal
that um that they don't have that as
much anymore that kids just don't think
about it you know it's not as much of a
thing so you know it I think you know
it's it's just good to hear because that
that's the truth that's if that's coming
out of a small town then that's the
truth
and these aren't two people that would
say anything to me to make me believe
anything different you know I mean I'm
still not saying that it's easy for some
people but I know that um it's nice to
hear you know from an educator you know
from educators that I personally trust
that it at young levels that a lot of
kids aren't thinking about that kind of
stuff anymore
you know I can't imagine what that's
like because the truth is the future of
the world man is beige it's beige power
because pay if you drive by people at
night if you look off in the distance
and people are at night they
everybody's a little bit mixed now you
know you do everything you know even if
somebody's still a little bit racist
they'll yell at somebody to get out of
their yard for being one color but then
they'll close the door and practice the
moonwalk you know or practice some
bachata or Macarena you know what I'm
saying like everybody's it's all merging
you know it's that beige power that's
what I say beige power it's all merging
what else man oh I thought about this
dude why does every small town have a
Deadman's curve in it how about this
don't have that that'd be a great idea
because people are dying and if anything
it even tempts young people they're like
Oh dead man's curve hear it count and
that's how it rolls out how about don't
hat for some reason every ever like
whenever we're driving around with all
these little little places here and
there I mean they have towns let me call
Bush son blond
just one word towns big branch that's
named after a stick I mean these
were all towns right over by me and
we're going into them everyone has a
Deadman's curve on the way in
beware of dead man's curve beware how
about don't have that just have
the street start to curve a little
earlier and just have kind of like a
little bit of a bend for a longer period
of time
there's something about small towns they
love that they love to have that chance
they love to have that chance of death
there ain't much to do let's uh
take dead man's curve at about 45 see if
the Lord wants us this week a man had a
good time so that's what I did this past
weekend I want some of you guys to hit
the hotline and just you know every now
and then you know we have the contest as
to what you did this past weekend we'll
give out a one of these Correctional
Center blue t-shirts every month we
still have to mail one to the first do
but don't worry man it's coming I've
been out of town a bunch but we're doing
that so don't worry and but hit the
hotline with what happened in your past
weekend nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three and let us know if
something good happen if something bad
happened let us know you know it's just
got to be 60 seconds or less and each
month we'll put together you know the
voicemails and we'll give away a prize
we might be adding some other prizes to
that as well
we're gonna bring Nick in in a minute
and talk about some things what else
happened to me mm-hmm oh I'll tell you
this
you know when I was young and if you're
on YouTube it just got a little dark in
here but that's because the powers went
out when I was young I got hit by a
Pontiac tire Firebird when I was young I
got hit by a Pontiac Firebird and I
don't know if anybody out there has ever
been hit by a car and if you have you
know we're I guess we're Eskimo twins
but I got hit I mean that thing I was
young you know and I would just left
running across to my mother just told me
something and I went back to listen to
her and then I took off running again
BAM got lit up on that thing and you can
still seal my calf on one of my calves
like by the side there's still uh you
know there's kind of a soft spot there
in my bone where that thing hit me
probably doing about 38 and I respected
that it was doing 38 miles an hour
because if you're doing anything less
than a 35 and a damn Pontiac Firebird
then our Trans Am then I couldn't even
respect you you know if I get hit by a
damn Trans Am going 6 miles an hour I
mean I would feel like a little
but you hit somebody at 38 you know that
actually you know it's not great but
it's does a little something for me a
little bit of street credit and that's
what I got you know I got that street
credit and it was beautiful man I mean
this is back in the day this is an 85 or
86 this is back when those things would
go 0 to 60 and about almost about nine
point two seconds 2.5 litre you know 5
p.m. kind of 5 p.m. blue or whatever
color was midnight black whatever it is
I don't know man I remember I just
remember that I remember to see in the
car that's all I remember
beautiful beautiful car but yeah those
are some of the things that popped into
my head going home going home to a small
town and just realizing that people just
like a slower way of life people liked I
mean I'm not an I'm waiting in line
everything's kind of people just like a
slower way of life and it feels good it
felt good to relax
we're going to get into some news where
get into some of you guys as calls Nick
is here you know we also have another
producer that's Chris Perez he's coming
in not today but I think we're going to
interview some do a couple of interviews
this week if you we have that Greyhound
breakdown we're going to do this week so
if you have a story about greyhounds
something that happened to you on
greyhound you hit us up at the hotline
nine eight five six six four nine five
zero three and leave a voicemail let us
know what happened and also if there's
something good that happened to you you
know there's a lot of joy that happens
on greyhound I saw two people get not
married but I saw two people get an old
I saw a marriage I think get an old
annulment you know and that's beautiful
when you get off at one stop and your ex
gets off at another and you got your
whole future ahead of you it's kind of
beautiful so you know there's some good
things that happens if you see if you
have something good that happened hit
the hotline as well and we'll get
involved in all of that this weekend I'm
gonna be in New Jersey at bananas comedy
club and bananas is a comedy club in
Hasbrouck Heights you can come through
that's April 20th and 21st as well I
will be at cluster fest in San Francisco
May sorry June 1st through 3rd Cherokee
Casino out in West Siloam Oklahoma and
that's June 9th Calgary June 15th and
16th at Yuk Yuk's in Canada and temblor
Brewing Company in Bakersfield June 23rd
the new website should be going live
this week where you guys can get
involved in more stuff and see more
what's going on all tickets and
everything available Thea Vaughn calm
man what a week I'm just tired did I
you're tired but I am happy to
be able to come home and be here with
you guys and I want to get to something
else calls and think about some things
with you guys and hear what's going on
in your life so also another weird thing
oh it's hard to keep telling you hit the
hotline but just if you wanted to hit
the hotline if you just tell me what you
do who are you who are you that listens
to this podcast hey Theo my name is
so-and-so and this is what I do for a
living and I have you know one or two or
three or four kids or no kids or you
know I'm homosexual or I'm straight edge
or I'm asexual or I'm
you know I'm just died in a fire I'm a
ghost whatever hit the hotline let me
know who you are if you feel like it
sometimes I just want to know who
listens so I can know that all right
we'll be back literally there's gonna no
giving me no commercial break we're
gonna stop right now and then we're
gonna be back we're gonna roast a couple
of songs as well see you in a second and
we are let's play one of the songs that
came in Nick I'm Nick Davis's in here
with me we are out here to laugh to joke
damn somebody sent this in out here -
laughs - joke this sounds like drug use
all right cut that off who's that from
that is Billy the Kid that's Billy the
Kid sent that in and that is uh what it
is sound like that's not like some dude
looking for something in a library I
feel like yeah it's something it sound
like he's on drugs walking through a
library looking for a book yeah when I
was young I was in the library and some
they had a boy and he could have been
Japanese or he could have just been kind
of you know just local and he um set my
hair on fire one time at a library and
one of my friends had to beat my hair
out with a periodical because it was
pretty lit yeah and that was you know
that's back though honestly when life
was more fun so that's what's crazy you
know the best childhood is supposed to
be more fun but that's the kind of
that was going down and they buried one
kid and thank God everybody dug
him up what else ma'am what else is
going let's get into some of the news
man thank you guys for being here with
this Nick just stepped in and and we got
some news some calls right what do we
have on yes sir we got some news first
there's some some heavy stuff went down
but some light-hearted stuff as well
first of all President Donald Trump
ordered a military strike on Syria early
Saturday in coordination with France and
Britain
the White House intended the strike to
deter Syrian President Bashar al Assad
from using chemical weapons after a
suspected attack using sarin and
chlorine gas killed dozens of people
last week in the rebel stronghold of
Duma Wow east of Damascus that's crazy
man so they ordered a military strike
yes sir and they got it yeah and we had
the approval of France and Britain our
allies mmm huh
let's say look man I mean it's like what
are you gonna do I mean I know they were
using gasses and stuff over there on
children and you saw pictures of that if
that's true then I mean it just is it's
just uncalled for
you know it's uncalled for so I know the
only thing is these days how do you like
go about like making sure nobody gets
hit and this this sort of thing but then
I think that that's where you get away
from like some of the country mentality
and just get into like an individual
mentality mm-hmm like when I was young
it was just like you know us against
another country do you remember that yes
yeah it was Russia
you just didn't you didn't think about
like each person and it's probably not
the best way to you know in some ways it
wasn't very humane probably because
you're not thinking about each
individual human but then that was I
think you know we're still coming off of
a colonial time where people were like
you know taking each other's land and
you know does that make any sense you
think yes definitely it's very confusing
who's associated with who we're bombing
Syria but it's somewhat to get to Iran
and Russia it's yeah definitely it
seemed like more black and white back in
the day but if sometimes outlook I like
a little something it almost makes you
feel you know makes you one who uh makes
you wanna you know hug your lady or
you know jerk often enables
neighbors mailbox or something or do
something wild because we know you know
I feel like when the missiles hit the
air sometimes it makes you just feel a
little bit more alive is that weird no
it's uh end times you got to get a half
you have your fun at the end yeah they
say if you're trapped in a freezer
somebody told me this one time that
you're trapped in a freezer that you
could that you can stay erect for like
it's it's almost impossible not to stay
oh right because your body starts to
think you're that you're dying and that
it wants to procreate and the same thing
like an
fire-like as you're burning you'll get
an erection man I'd hate to see you on
fire while you're in a plane you'd what
kind of erection you'd have that oh
that's a good plan of a plane's going
down boy somebody's getting that free
hit what else we got former first lady
barbara Bush is in failing health and
she has decided not to seek further
treatment a source close to the family
said the 92 year old former first lady
is being cared for at her home in
Houston and has two decided she does not
want to go back to the hospital
she has been on oxygen for some time and
she's currently joined by her family
including former President George HW
Bush and former Governor Jeb Bush and
former president W Bush oh man that's
always thought that she looked like
honestly you know and that's you know
she um but she should probably seem like
a nice lady I just always thought that
she you know that George W Bush didn't
chase a lot of hotties you know that but
that's back when I mean he kind of took
that rosie the riveter type of chick
that tough she looked like she could
have been early MMA you know early
grassroots type of stuff maybe she
fought in Charleston a couple times you
know maybe she fought in Lexington
maybe she fought over in Birmingham or
Meridian Mississippi you know maybe one
time got out to Oklahoma for like some
sort of you know battle of the of the
Bulge kind of a you know middle of the
country sort of thing but she looks like
she definitely could have probably cut a
fist fall it she looked kind of a tough
brawl it definitely I could see her
fighting Don Frye one of their early UFC
stars oh yeah or a big Kamal I remember
that guy yes yeah okay who else man what
else anything else in the news yet see a
daycare worker reportedly built a drug
den inside a Missoula Montana YMCA
Learning Center the facility's laundry
room was outfitted with a
battery-powered light makeshift curtains
shelves in an air filter and a small
glitter case containing snort tubes
lighters Gang Gang
glass pipe and a vial of methamphetamine
we're all found there you go man we'll
look and I and I've always figured this
day care and drug use
how can you you can't outlaw it
because you're telling me you're gonna
drop your kids off by me and
look most of these daycares dude I would
used to work at one I think it was
called a okay ranch or some fake name
and people would drop their kids off all
day we had him in a long it was a
trailer it was basically an empty
trailer that we put different like
letters alphabet on the wall
and wouldn't even have all the
letters we had to draw some of the
letters on the wall so we had some real
letters some drawn on letters or painted
on and then we would have we had kids
aged 4 to I think 12 all in the same
room in this big trailer who watch
movies and they would change clothes
behind these men's and women's curtains
in the back and we take them to swim in
this big sister and that somebody had
spilled a bunch of damn flour powder in
and so the water was all chalky so we'd
take him down the hill to swim in there
who even knew what was in that bro
you couldn't see the bottom of the
bottom was literally only about 14
inches away and then one time this man
named Wild Bill would come down he'd
take photos of the kids and stuff you
know for like about three weeks so I go
to my boss one day big TIFF this lady
that ran it and I was like you know do
we ever get to see the pictures from mr.
bill and she's like who's mr. bill and
I'm like the photographer she's like we
don't have a photographer she just like
you know we don't even have electricity
here in the front building oh Mack well
boy somebody's been coming out
we've been posing with him did we were
doing pyramids and like throwing kids up
in the air and stuff and you know it's
just so you're telling me that these
people are watching kids all day and
they can't do a little bit of dope here
there take a hit and here's the thing as
a parent you know what you're getting
when you drop your kid off you can tell
when you if you get there and they got a
little fence or something you know where
they're put or they got you know the
lady has pepper spray around her neck
you know what the you're getting
into so I don't blame the
I don't know if I blame the people that
are working there trying to have a side
hustle make a little bit of dope you
know it's tough times you know do I
think that they should be doing that
around kids and cooking up
methamphetamines around kids no I don't
but do I blame them for trying to run
two businesses at the same time and not
being sure which way to go you know I
don't understand it because it's it's
hard nobody wants your shitty kids well
because here's the thing a lot of times
though kids are either good like I find
my brothers kids sometimes are good when
they're around me and they'll be bad or
when they're around him but sometimes
that's not the case man you know and if
these people need to you know have a
side hustle then do it
I mean I'm glad this unit have the kids
involved in it don't know that for me is
uh that's a no-no what else do we have
actor Will Ferrell escaped from a
violent car car crash relatively
unscathed the actor suffered minor
injuries after the SUV he was riding in
flipped over on a Los Angeles freeway
late Saturday night
wow we're going to the quad could you
imagine that if Will Ferrell got into a
car accident by you the the weird thing
about some celebrities it's hard not to
run up on them and I think expect them
to make you laugh like what if you ran
up to Will Ferrell he's dying you've to
do CPR on him I think I'd be laughing
too like it would seem like he was
joking he was coming back from a San
Diego funny or die event and he was in
character as Ron Burgundy
yeah so I don't I don't know if when
they got hit he was in character but
again it just adds to it yeah if he
rolls out as Ron Burgundy I mean there's
no way you know and he's coming back
from San Diego I mean it all kind of
fits there's no way he's like like
what's that Baxter there's Jesus in and
there's cheese in in the orphans bedroom
all right cool let's get to a couple of
calls man what do we got Nate we got
Bryce what's that do this is Bryce from
Fresno okay thank you for calling Bryce
I appreciate you hitting the hotline
homeward I'm just wanted to tell you a
little about a little bit about what's
going on with you
disgust weakened me and my wife we made
an offer to buy a home and we're really
excited man it's a big deal for us and
especially with me like buying a house
in my family like that's not too common
you know and my grandma she
unfortunately lost her home and you know
I couldn't tell you man how many times
we moved when I was a kid and I just
didn't want that for my family you know
going through the process right now and
I got a badass wife you know that
supports me and stuff and we make a good
team and starting like a new chapter in
our lives you know so yeah I just want
to share that with you thanks for
calling Bryce I appreciate that that's
amazing man you got first-time home
ownership and I think you know in my
family yeah I guess you know we rented
growing up but to have that first-time
home ownership that's huge
and you sound like you might be Latino
or Guatemalan I mean you might be
American as well but you all might also
know Spanish or you have a lisp that
likes Mexican food I mean these are all
possibilities but I can't even imagine
what that's like to be the first one in
your family because you're gonna start
to set a precedent you know you know
your family's gonna become homeowners
you know now somebody and your family's
gonna look at you like oh that's uncle
Bryce you know that's my dad and he's a
homeowner you know he pays his mortgage
he you know you know your home is gonna
be something have an example of
something that you take care of you know
you you know you get flower beds you and
your wife are gonna have some traditions
you'll be able to build and those are
some things that I think a lot of you
know families that travel a lot or move
around a lot or families that get you
know get stuck in just renting you don't
get you don't get as much of that you
know I remember one of the things that I
loved is I got older was running down
the staircase you know and it just
became a thing where I could like it at
some point I was small enough to slide
down the rail a little bit we had to say
it was just a piece of rail like
along this wall
and then I got too big to slide down and
I had to just you know that I had to get
back to running and but then as I got
older I could literally make it all the
way down the staircase in like four
steps if I wanted to and I just
remembered that was always some weird
monitor in my head that was like man
used to have to like hold on to the rail
with both hands when you would go down
these and it's just you know it's wild
how you have like these little things in
your home you'll start to remember you
know I would always get jealous when I
would go over to kids houses and they
had like that thing on the wall that
show where the kids had grown up and it
kept getting taller you know because it
just shows some little bit of history I
remember you know I remember like I
remember taking out the garbage and
things like that and going out to the
gate and how the gate would scare me and
at night and do that night when you're a
kid anything could be in the air
anything a star might attack you a
wolf a tree the ground might
swallow you somebody with a hatchet
might show up it was always somebody
that for me was like with a hatchet like
I've never even seen a hatchet
my whole life but in my imagination they
had five they just hide in
the shadows hatchet ready just looking
for somebody just like me I mean under
there's a kind of scary thoughts to be
thinking about a home ownership but you
can have nice stuff man you gonna be
able to buy things and put it in your
house that's gonna become your domain
that's amazing man congratulations dude
I you know I can't now I don't know if I
can know of a better weekend I don't
know if I can know of a better weekend
than having that first feeling to being
a homeowner so congratulations to you
you're gonna set a precedent your family
it sounds like will become a new thing
what else we got Nick you know waking up
this morning to the passing of Mitzi
shore was a rough one that was the first
thing I saw as soon as I opened my eyes
looked at my phone went on Instagram and
it's like one of those people
that you like like Stanley and I don't
play it's one person I was like man
I I know it's gonna happen and it's
gonna be really shitty to wake up in the
morning going to see you know
that passing so rest in peace mr. Shore
yeah thanks for calling about this man
yummy Mitzi shore passed away and I was
out of town I was out of town and I felt
I mean personally I felt the first
thought I had was that I felt bad for
Paulie yeah I mean you know paulie's one
of I mean he's definitely one of a kind
he's the only person that you know that
grew up just there really in that Club I
mean he has two brothers Scott and Peter
but you know Paul is just the one that I
kind of know so I just felt I mean my
first thought is felt bad for him as a
son you know I can't imagine that I
can't imagine like this there must be
some type of a connection thing that
probably happens to a man when they're
when their mother passes away you know
because that's like your um you know you
guys were connected that was like your
life force and then that's gone you know
I'd love to read up and and find out
there's like something that happens in
our brains or inside of us when that
kind of happens but yeah I just felt
really you know I just felt for Paulie
and then I thought about this this club
you know that this lady made this club
because the the Comedy Store changed my
life changed my life you know more than
any building on earth besides the
hospital that I was born in the Comedy
Store changed my life I mean it's a
place that has just given me so many
opportunities and and I just wouldn't
even have the little successes that I
have today if it wasn't for their a lot
of the friends that I have that places
helped me build up confidence on stage
which is carried itself offstage a place
also man great place to buy some cocaine
and party meet some good plus or chill
out or if you're looking for that
and everything you get anything you want
at the Comedy Store and to think that
this lady started this a woman started
to make me think about feminism too at
first I was I was thinking man well this
is the kind of feminism out that off
that I that makes sense to me is a woman
just doing whatever she wants to do you
know I mean I mean people say they can't
do this is they can't do that this woman
started one of the
latest comedy clubs in the world if not
thee and and this is 40 46 years ago she
started it and it's just been you know
it's had its ups and downs but it's it
beat out all the rest and she was a you
know she she controlled the stage she
said who passed and who didn't I mean
you want to talk about a glass ceiling
there wasn't one
if there was it was it was a female you
know she was the one she was she was you
know that just made me think wow I'm a
that's the first time I just felt
oh that's feminism right there you know
you want to see a woman just do
something and at the same time have the
natural powers that a woman has boom
there you go you know that's not talking
about it or tweeting about it or making
a poster board or something
that's just getting out there and live
in life and at the same time happening
happening to be a woman you know
sometimes it just makes it you know like
Beyonce perform this weekend at
Coachella do you see that I did and
she's like the first black person ever
headline Coachella you know and to me
it's like well who cares like why does
it always it's it's so strange sometimes
like you know people are like it's you
know I'm the first black on the first
Asian I'm the first woman but I'm going
to me I guess if I don't think of things
that like that then it's like one but
then those are the same people where
it's like well it doesn't matter that
I'm black or a woman or I'm Asian to me
it's just like why does it always have
to be I don't know why does always have
to be something that make any sense neck
yeah pointing out these differences are
these first only separate us rather than
looking at us all all the same people
for sure yeah yeah I guess it's like
yeah I guess at a certain point some of
the stuff feels like well it just does
it feel separating you know like oh I
thought it was just awesome because
somebody's performing you know and now
it's like oh now it's just a now it
feels like oh it's not for everybody but
then I guess you know there's this chip
on a lot of people's shoulder where this
just you know I saw Charlize Theron the
other day was talking about how you know
she didn't know if it's safe to raise
her kids in America
because of the racism the tear you know
but at the same time I'm in my hometown
this weekend and I specifically asked
some of the educators that are at the
the junior high where I went to about
race stuff I was like what is racial
stuff like these days and they said it's
just it's nothing like it used to be you
know and that made me feel pretty good
and isn't Charlize Theron from South
Africa like the most racist place that's
a good point I think we're better than
there to be honest yeah oh I definitely
think so too I think it's more I think
she if she if she didn't watch the news
as much she would probably you know
think of his a blast or think it wasn't
as bad as she thought it could be I'm
exhausted today man what else we
got Nick this came in from Layla I
filled my name is Lila hey Layla thank
you for calling thank you for calling
homeward discovered you through siren
rex and and then just it was love at
first sight
anyways I am currently married and I've
been married for about three years
literally three years in September and
my husband is a recovering addict and he
relapsed this evening so I'm home alone
and he hasn't come home and I'm worried
about him and he's a he's a really good
man you know he's trying he just started
his own business he just took over a
business and I apparently the man that
the guy that he took over the business
from he he does a little bit of the of
the of the toe killing you know carry
cane or my coke and I guess he's been a
bad influence on my husband and anyways
if anybody could just offer some
encouraging words of wisdom my husband
is really a good man
I just don't know really where to go
from here okay well I appreciate you
calling young lady yeah I can imagine
that that's got to be really tough for
for you you know if you're dealing with
that sort of thing I know that there is
Allen on meetings where you can go you
know if you have a family member or a
spouse or whatever that you know
struggles with addiction you can go and
learn how to deal with them and I'm sure
you know those things I'm not trying to
pre-chat you just trying to share in
case there's people out there that don't
know that if they are you know if they
live in a home with is a you know
somebody who's an alcoholic or they
think they may be that there's help out
there for you not the alcoholic there's
help out there for you by going to
al-anon meetings yeah I'm sorry I'm
sorry your husband's dealing with that I
mean I worry you know what's funny as
you talk as you're telling me he
relapsed my first thought was the first
thought that bubbled into me the first
it was jealousy it's like man I
would only be out there you know a
little bit of just a little bit of
jealousy like damn lucky guy
and that's the thing in you that makes
you want to just go party and do stuff
you know that's that dark art that's
living inside you man that's that
you know that's that that's that
medieval Picasso that says that's inside
me just putting paint on everything you
know just putting dark paint on my
insides because he wants me to be dark
and he wants me to behave that way and
you know I'm sure sitting at home
waiting for him is is tough I mean if
you said he has that influence that's
how I mean that's hard I mean it's hard
to be in a I don't they I could go into
business with somebody who's doing
cocaine I couldn't do it now I'm not
preaching at your husband I couldn't do
it
dude look my biggest fear is some fine
chick showing up with a ball no you know
nice-looking butthole and that's it you
know and that's just next thing you know
I'm in outer space son you know I'm up
there buzz aldrin and round somebody's
ass so that's one of my biggest fears so
uh and it's plus it the stresses of the
new business this and that I can imagine
there's a lot of pressure but I'm sorry
you having to deal with that you know
I'm sure that it's probably tough and
you know and I'm sure you know you just
have to be supportive and you don't want
to reprimand you don't want to probably
say too much because you know he already
has enough on his plate but I'll say
this one amazing thing about that
program the AAA program and sobriety is
he can always come back you know those
people they don't judge you when you
walk back into the room most people
don't know they don't remember
you know it's your journey it's
his journey and he can always go back
you know imagine I'm in a place you can
always go to no matter what I mean I
don't know if I ever felt like sometimes
in my life that I had that and that's
one thing in those rooms of sobriety
offer for people but I appreciate you
calling and sharing that with us and I
hope that um that he made it home that
things are looking at in a different
direction now you know and maybe next
time uh maybe we just recommend that he
speak with his sponsor if he's going you
know in the business or what's going on
in business circles because yeah I am so
grateful that nobody I know you know I
see some people sometimes that are
running around with them you can hear it
in their pocket
dude I could hear a little bag of
cocaine for about eighty feet away son
am i can hear that but thank you
for calling sweetheart I hope that uh I
hope it gets better I'll be thinking of
you let's hear more Nick what else we
got alright here we go
hey yo man this is Dylan from Texas
alright thank you for calling Dylan and
but I had a question for you about
alcoholism mm-hmm
from 25 I got a college degree I got a
degree in welding I will pipe okay I am
boy you that matter huh get that fit uh
you that pipe Feder dude I used to know
a dude he used to go welding underwater
that was this thing he worked for like
the oil rig and he'd be out there
just welding all kind of sitting
underwater I'm like did he sure that you
have a real job because that sounds
fictional man I don't know how they
would work let's hear more company and I
take care of my girl and my
four-year-old son and we got a house and
all that but it's real stressful man so
what I've been doing is uh go get a
six-pack into little airplane bottles of
whiskey every day
and right now I'm sitting my garage and
drinking a beer and I used to do drugs
and all that and I used to do other
stuff but I just wander man do you think
that that's alcoholism because I drank
every day then two cigars I limited I
limited myself to a six pack and two
shots
wonder if that's gonna be something more
well look man you used to do drugs you
said and other things I don't know what
that is
you know juggling throwing
knives at your neighbors I mean anything
kind of AD that could be anything
you know burying people you just met I
don't know
but only you know that answer I can't
tell you if you're not called you could
drink a pint of gin a day I don't even
know how much a pine is or six pints and
you might you might be you might not you
know there's functioning alcoholism the
thing that I noticed for me is that I
use it as an assumed the biggest thing I
recognize in hindsight of having a and
having taken a respite from drinking
coming up on two years here of drinking
no drinking or drugs is that I used I
used alcohol as an escape you know I use
cocaine as an escape that's the thing
something I've learned is that now I'm
facing more things and I've learned that
my life is therefore advancing more
because for me I wasn't really addicted
to a drug or an alcohol I was addicted
to not wanting to see myself I was
addicted to not wanting to feel my
feelings and so when it came moments
where I felt like I needed to or I was
about to then I would I would resort to
doing a drug you know and so that's what
it did for me and so I find now that I
don't do that that I don't have that
escape that I battle more like it's when
things come up instead of been like aw
all this it would be you know then
I find that oh now I'm from when things
come up I battle that thing and I
learned to the figure the thing out and
if I can't figure it out then I could
now I have people that I can call that I
can say hey I have this issue what would
you do and they've been in the program
for 10 years or 20 years and they'll say
oh this is what I learned to do and then
I do what they learn sometimes and then
that's how my life gets better because
I'm not thinking for myself and I'm not
escaping my issues now I'm not saying
you have issues you may not you may not
but if
you find that you're escaping things and
that's why you drank them didn't you may
only you know I can't tell you if you're
an alcoholic only you know and I'm not
gonna accuse you of being one you might
be that dude you met who's the guy on um
Nick on that cartoon where they all
drink outside of the house king of the
hill yeah Hank Hill yeah Hank Hill you
might be the main star dude I'm a
no-name who's in broome our what's that
guy's name boom are ya boom our okay I
can't do any of it but okay hunk dude I
was trying to work on a J Maura did nor
McDonald I was trying to work on that
heroes coming along a little yeah you're
getting is much better than your first
attempt on the Jay Mohr episode yeah
sure any of our heroes somebody's dead I
got to work on it
what else we got on April 12 state
lawmakers a Louisiana passed a bill
making it illegal for a human to have
sex with an animal there you go and now
I'm acres passed the vote 122 to 6 okay
there you go so six people voted no on
that which seems bizarre but I'm gonna
tell you why six people would vote no
yes if you are doing sexual actions with
a animal that is a small animal you know
or an animal that isn't fast then yeah
you should go to jail okay this stuff
this stuff with Bichons and you know
River Rats or whatever all that stops
now but if you are a cheetah in
the wild or a Lynx or a mountain cat
you are never buying a beer again as far
as I'm concerned you're a hero that's
not bestiality some dude is dating a
white wolf
that's not bestiality guy okay lawmakers
that guy is a damn American icon that
guy you put
and on YouTube game over
okay views central I'm telling you this
if I meet a man who's been making love
to a wolf in the wild that man eats for
free by my house I'm talking free
everything free meat free tots free
everything by me so that's my bestiality
thoughts let's take another call Nick
what do we got hey this is CJ from
Dallas just last Friday a toad heed and
on fentanyl and heroin and I am now
going to be being shipped off to
Jacksonville Florida Duval Cowan do whoa
this Saturday to be an inpatient rehab
center for the following three months
I've been a big flower of this past
weekend for about a year now I made it
to your shower and asked and last August
and got myself a journal and I'm really
anxious regarding these next three
months and just how to fill the time in
my day at this rehab side you
know I really don't want to be stuck
with the roommate who talked to the wall
all night cheeks his meds and like
that it can be weird but I guess I was
just hoping to get some advice on what
to do you know I'm gonna be disconnected
from technology good man well I think
you gotta be you know I think honestly
one thing that struggles of that help
that's not good for me right now is uh
sometimes there's too much technology
for me to even get through some of my
own program you know I have to start
making more room for my light in my life
for my program my 12 steps and my
sobriety that sort of thing but dude if
you go into treatment I promise you they
will surround you with things to do you
know just listen for the similarities
not the differences that's what I hear
and then just get you know just I don't
know I can't tell you what to anything
to do because I don't really know you
know I just know that at the core of me
and at the core of everyone I bet
there's
something that they want you to feel
better so and you want to be well
somewhere inside of you there's a part
of you that really really wants to be
well so that it can do well you know
that's the that's that that for me is
that is the worst part sometimes is you
know is knowing that when I don't treat
myself good that myself isn't able to do
its best work you know that's the
toughest thing for me sometimes but
you'll be you'll be busy you'll meet a
lot of friends look if you're willing to
call in here I bet you'll be willing to
speak to you know speak to others and
see what's going on and I'm glad you
made it out back out in Addison and I
wish you well in the three months and
hit me up when you get out when I come
to Addison again I'm gonna try to
schedule some dates I'll get you some
tickets man be my guest we'll hit an a a
meeting down there together dude that'd
be dope I went to one not far from the
club last time I was there so we'll hit
a room and you get it you stay in those
three months man we'll hit a meeting
when you get out so I'll put that on the
table for you
what else we got Nick anything else yes
one more call all right
sorry I'm just brushing through these
tonight guys I'm just man I I just I'm
just feeling tired all right let's take
another call hey man I'm calling to talk
about an issue we got going on down here
Houston Texas okay yeah I
mean they should call it that dude
Houston is uh it's it's quite a place
let's hear more right we got it we got a
thing down here called shoulder syndrome
okay the What did he say yep
shoulder syndrome shoulder
syndrome okay let's hear about it all
right triple-s it's going on down here
dude the stuff they don't exercise and
the reason is because internet
dating man because boots don't have to
go out and attract women yeah in the
field they get to put on a pretty ass
like a pretty ass shirt and a nice
little flak jacket like they're in the
army and take some pictures and
put a filter and throw that fit up on
the Internet
and then they get to sit there
tore through all the women and then when
they actually do go out in public they
got a chip on their shoulder against
women and that leaves them depressed and
then they for sure ain't gonna try to do
a pushup
and this all culminates into this fifty
stoller syndrome well hey I appreciate
you calling man thank you very much for
that you know it's uh I know there's a
lot of things happening out there
so I'm not surprised this could be
happening but here's what I'm thinking
is first of all some acute some issues
with the army you know me you drop that
in that was kind of a little wild really
a little wild ingredient there you know
that's like putting a Spanish moss into
a you know betcha Jamaican
oatmeal that really I didn't understand
that and you you could be right I mean
there's people that aren't so you're
saying and is this right Nick he's
saying that people aren't working out
because they don't have to extend off to
impress women in person anymore like a
man don't have to be you know like that
you know that you know the peacock
exactly and instead they're doing it
online so you can peacock online so you
can bait online and then once you get
them live then you have to actually show
up and the second interaction that real
in person men aren't in shape and
they're not taking care of themselves so
the reality it's not the sales pitch
isn't landing on the women once they
meet them that sounds like it and which
leads to depression which leads to
further not working out
okay rejection which leads to further
not working out I mean this guy could
sell gym memberships I don't know what
this guy does you know that shifty
soldier syndrome a soldier
syndrome I mean first of all if you're
gonna use an acronym you got to make it
one everybody can say bro I'm saying you
catch one do with a list B anyone be
able to say that so you need to
make it one that people can say but I
mean I certainly agree that there's it's
it's different now you know with
technology it's like we don't you know a
lot of your peacocking is done online
you know like nerds kind of in inherit
the world because
we don't need that fizz it's not about
strength anymore but you know it's not
about brute strength like it used to be
I mean I think that there's still you
know some places where it's where it is
I mean you know it's in you know some
small towns this weekend and some of
those places they don't even have
Netflix they don't they don't care you
talk about Netflix they don't want it
they watch television because that's
what they grew up watching you know and
they spend more time doing family stuff
and you know and interact and with
others than they do as connect to do
electronics and everything like we are
in these bigger cities so you get out
there they're not on the Netflix
you know like I'm like I got a comedian
like John Mulaney who would you know
sell out here in Los Angeles he self 30
tickets you know in the town where I'm
from but Dave Coulier from full house
would sell out you know each sell four
nights there so a lot of it is that
people you know it's just that you know
some people aren't evolving as much they
don't want to they just don't want to be
as connected so in those kind of places
I think it's still you know whoever's
the you know the of the walk the
big rooster you know whoever's peacock
and the most is probably going to end up
meeting the most women and impressing
the most women but then you get into
different places and any Muppet you know
with a with a fancy filter can be
whoever they want to be now there still
comes that second that second
interaction where you have to actually
meet and you know I think that's when
you still have to be a human right now
yes definitely I think it's
short-sighted of these guys not to work
out because like you said that second
interaction comes if you look like a
muppet you're not gonna get in the
anyway so yeah stay in the gym yeah stay
ticking yeah stay taking carries I'll
stay doing something you know there's
still has to be that second interaction
now it could come I mean I wouldn't be
shocked if there's people in Los Angeles
who are married that have never even met
each other you know that just you know
met each other electronically and now
they're married and they you know eat
meals over FaceTime and that's how they
do it because they look best at certain
angles
and maybe that's best for them and that
could be the future you could marry
somebody then you each go to your
separate room
you know you each live in your own
houses you watch your own pornography
that get you off and then you let you
know you are in your own little world
but you're still married you know you
have children that live in incubators at
the hospital and someone comes in and
feeds them but they look at you all day
over a screen and they look at your wife
all day and there you are and you're
connected and that is the future and it
could be in the future that if you touch
somebody that it alarms them you know
that they don't even know what the
sensation is one day if you touch
someone else's skin
I mean pornography has done so much of
that I think to to men especially that
it's everything so visual now for men
whereas it used to be more sensual I
think things have gotten very very
visual for men where in the old days it
was you know you touched a woman or you
you know you saw a lady you know with
even if she had long arm hair and she
had a drop of sweat coming off one of
them hairs under her arms she would who
this was like a damn waterfall it
was beautiful you know if she's if that
his drop a sweat hit the air from
whatever armpit hairs you'd catch that
thing in your mouth you know and you
wouldn't even swallow it because you'd
hold it in your mouth for good luck but
those times have changed you know now
everything's electronic now everything
we just wanted to look a certain way
things have gotten so visual and one of
the scary things about that is that is
that you don't get a reflection of who
you are like me as a person when I used
to be depressed and stay inside for a
long time I didn't do anything I just
stayed inside and I started to think I
was a bad person and and and that
feeling started to grow and that
depression started to grow and the
reason it did was because I wasn't
seeing other people and when I see other
people I realize that I'm not a bad
person because I can see the look in
their eyes and the look in their eyes
back to me usually is that I'm an okay
person that I may be said something nice
or you know try to do something friendly
or I shared where I could and you need
that Phoebe
you need that reflection of yourself you
know other humans that's the best mirror
for your emotions you know when you see
another human you get that emotion that
feeling like oh I'm okay you know that
person just looked at me and smiled or
that person just nodded or that person
you know asked me if everything is going
well you know when you feel that
connection when you feel that you know
when you feel that you're not a bad
person you feel that reflection coming
off of another human
then you that starts to live in you but
when you don't see people the other
thing starts to live in you you know
that dirty dark warlord you know that
just that painful Picasso does inside of
you just painting up your whole inner
inner world with dark paints and dark
arts and it gets nasty and if you if you
stay by yourself man that depression
grows it is an algae it is a moss it
grows and it'll grow up over and over in
and over you until it's above you it's
sitting on the top of whatever water you
live in and it's like an algae it's us
and then you're in a swamp and you got
to get out of there and see other people
and get a reflection of yourself and a
smile sprout a smile that's a flower
right there a smile is a flower that
just flew out of your face and let those
things live in the world and that feels
good and other people will look at you
they'll see your smile like all right
guys okay and you'll feel that oh that
person thinks I'm okay and you get that
reflection from somebody else that
you're not a bad person and that lives
inside of you and so don't swamp out
don't stay swampy at the house get out
take a walk you're not a bad person if
you're feeling depressed
get out meet somebody say hey you'll be
okay I promise you it'll help man I
promise it'll help I think that's all I
got I'm so man you know I'm just I want
to talk about more things and I want to
listen to more voicemails but we're
gonna do that Greyhound breakdown coming
up right Nick yes sir we got a driver
coming in hopefully oh yeah
that's awesome so we're gonna do that
greyhound
breakdown I think tomorrow we're gonna
tape that and we'll put it up later this
week we got a driver coming in and we're
gonna try to get some other guess we got
a I know back page shut down the escort
section so we're gonna try to get an
escort in how is that looking Nick it
looks like we've got a couple couple
warm leads okay a lot of these ladies
are admitted obviously a little bit
skeptical about being interviewed about
their profession especially with the
crackdown but we got some leads and
hopefully we're gonna have one coming in
soon okay great and if you know somebody
in the Los Angeles area that's an escort
or has worked in the escorting industry
you know I don't frown on that industry
I mean I frown on the sex trafficking
and that sort of stuff obviously but you
know I wouldn't want my sister a mother
in it probably you know but I know that
there are women in it and I'm not not
gonna you know I'm not gonna think that
those are bad people just because you
know they're doing something that's
different than what I would do but I
don't look down upon it you know that's
someone's job and and that opportunity
is being taken away from them with
Backpage escorts section being shut down
so if you know someone in the Los
Angeles area have them hit the hotline
we can do audio only interview and and
you know keep their anonymity intact
that number is nine eight five six six
four nine five zero three get connected
man get connected with this past weekend
what else oh we got our gift that came
in I want to this came in an email and a
message smells good the shirt it says
original condition original factory
CENTCOM missed that new-car smell this
says howdy Theo my name is Joe and I'm
from Amarillo Texas and Amarillo means
what yellow yellow oh wow
yellow Texas my dad and I run a small
business selling new car smell air
fresheners and I've included some of
them in this package for you to try in
your own car ooh
and if you could see these things boy
this looks like about a cold 40
kilograms that's you know that
new car scent bro I'll smoke a damn bowl
of this bro
cuz I can leave this isn't drugs I
wanted to let you know your podcast has
been very inspirational to me over the
past year I've listened to it since day
one I'm 25 years old working towards the
goal of being able to support my family
with this business one day it's very
difficult not to get discouraged or feel
like a loser sometimes when others I
know chose a different route going to
college or working a different type of
job listening to the podcast and hearing
you discuss your own trials and
tribulations in a different industry has
given me the strength to keep going on
the hardest today so uh thanks dude
a sweet of you to say bro listening to
the podcast and hearing you discuss your
own trials and tribulations in a
different industry has given me the
strength to keep going on the hardest of
days thanks man
that's that's nice of you man and uh
appreciate that I'm grateful to you for
being real with your listeners and being
honest about your struggles I think
you're positively affecting more people
than you know with your words I know I'm
not the only person that appreciates
this thanks brother god bless and that's
from that's Joe from Emory oh and he
sent me a couple of hits of this new car
stuff and this say missed that new car
smell original factory scent and I'm
gonna go on your site Joe and I'm gonna
buy some and I'm gonna send them to two
people that hit up this past weekend and
try and send in their weekend and win
that shirt and we'll include a few of
these with the shirts as they go out
over the next couple months in that
contest thank you man it's nice of you I
don't work for this company Joe didn't
pay me or send me anything you know to
put it put to put this on the show I'm
just I appreciate it that's nice if you
do that made me feel good and and you're
welcome you know I'm just out here bro
you know I'm just trying to stay alive
and and you guys helped me so much by
you know by sending me nice notes and
stuff like that that made me feel good
so you know we all need to feel good you
know sometimes I think like we all try
to be so different you know to stand out
you know we want to be different and we
want to stand out but the truth is we
don't want to you know the truth is we
just want to feel like somebody cares
about us you know we just want
feel like somebody appreciates us you
know it's like we'll try so hard to be
so different just to be included just to
feel like we're all this just to feel
like we're the same we just want to feel
like we're the same you know at our core
somewhere we just want to feel like
we're the same and that's all I've ever
wanted to feel man I believe that you
guys be good to yourselves we'll be back
this week with a couple of great
episodes Nick you have any closing
thoughts bud I'm just excited for the
cast of characters we're gonna be having
walk through here and a couple of themed
episodes that sound really fun yeah
that's true we got that Greyhound
breakdown I mean the stories of the
emails alone that I've gotten Wow
everything from pregnancy to to loss you
know a lot of stuff a lot of rare drugs
and everything thank you guys for being
here with this this weekend I'll see you
guys in New Jersey this week but also
I'll see you guys on that Thursday
episode I'll be good to yourselves you
probably deserve it that's nice and this
is just Spencer Jacob growl with
celebrate and you can find the link to
that in the episode thank you gun squad
for your support I hope you caught that
Thursday episode on patreon
celebrate
[Music]
as always brought to you by gray block
pizza
[Music]
great block pizza for that pizza that
you need
that's 18 11 Pico Boulevard
[Music]
let's have some fun while we all die
alright guys see y'all soon
[Music]